يجتمعوا بمدرب مانشستر يونايتد اصابه
نيمار تستفز جماهير باريس اجتماع بين
والدي ميسي ورئيسي برشلونه هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
رغم ابتعاده عن الامور الفنيه وحياه
التدريب اجتمع اسطوره مانشستر يونايتد
السرعه بمدرب الفريق في احد مطاعم المدينه
والتقطت صور للثنائي وهما يتناولان العشاء
ويتحدثان قبل المواجهه الحاسمه التي ستجمع
النادي الانجليزيه بنادي برشلونه الاسباني
وايضا قبل المواجهه الهامه للفريق ضد
نيوكاسل في بطوله الدوري
جماهير نادي باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي
استيائها على السوشيال ميديا من اصابات
نيمار المتكرره خلال هذا الوقت من الموسم
وابدت الجماهير رده فعل غاضبه على صفحات
نادي عبر مواقع التواصل بعد الكشف عن حجم
اصابه النجم البرازيلي الاخيره حيث اصبح
غياب نيمار في هذه الفتره من الموسم
مالوفا ومتزامنا ايضا مع خروجي باريس من
دوري الابطال في كل موسم
نبقى مع اخبار لاعبي سان جيرمان حيث كشف
راديو كتالونيا عن اجتماع الجامعه
نادي برشلونه قبل عده ساعات وبحسب
التقارير الاسبانيه فن الاجتماع تناول
امكانيه عوده ميسي بالاضافه الى تصريحات
شقيقه المثيره للجدل وياتي هذا الاجتماع
عقب الانباء المتداوله عن عدم تجديد سان
جيرمان لعقد ميسي الذي سينتهي بنهايه
الموسم الحالي
في خبر الاخير نيتن جونز كان قبل نحو
اسبوعين فقط يجلسوا على ديكاتي بودره
افريقيا
في البريميرليج لكنه اقيل بسبب سوء
النتائج جونز لم يرد الابتعاد عن كره
القدم وعاد للاعب مع فريقه يشارك في دور
الهواتف الامور لم تتوقف عند هذا الحد
جونز وبعد لاعبه لعده دقائق اضطرر لمغادره
الملعب بعد تعرضه لاصابه في الركبه